A new "Fifty Shades" movie hits
theatres this weekend, in case
you were wondering why there was
a buzzing sound coming from your
mom's locked bedroom.
(laughter and groaning)
In an interesting wrinkle, the
cast has been forbidden from
talking about kinky sex during
press interviews.
So without the sex, "Fifty
Shades" is just a movie about a
boring man and a woman who
sometimes sit in a helicopter.
I don't know what...
That's about it.
This is even more surprising,
because the movie co-stars
Marcia Gay Harden, whose name
already sounds like a sex thing.
(laughter)
Comedians, how would you
describe BDSM sex in a
family-friendly way?
Uh, Jay. Jay.
>> Sticks and stones may break
my bones, but it's the only way
I can come anymore.
>> HARDWICK: All right, great.
Points.
(laughter, applause & cheering)
Points. Annie.
>> It's about love, leather, and
women sliding off their seats at
movie theatres.
(laughter, cheering)
>> HARDWICK: Yeah, all right,
points.
>> 'Cause they're so excited
that they sweat in their
underwear, in their underwear.
>> HARDWICK: And they sweat in
their... yeah, yeah, that's what
you meant.
That's what you meant.
Josh, what do you think?
>> Uh, look, kids, I have an
anger problem, so it's either
you or your dad.
>> HARDWICK: All right, points.
Points. Yeah, very good.
(laughter, applause & cheering)